the undocumented immigrants suspected of
driving drunk and killing Indianapolis
Colts player Edwin Jackson and his uber
driver is now facing federal charges
Manuel Omega subala is charged with
illegal reentry of a previously deported
alien he is expected back in court today
where he could face more charges dean
reynolds has been looking into Savalas
criminal history he's outside Lucas Oil
Stadium that's the home of the
Indianapolis Colts Dean good morning
good morning well Edwin Jackson was
looking forward to playing another
season of football here next year but
now his alleged killers to deportations
and many run-ins with the law are coming
under intense scrutiny Manuel or agus
avala denied driving the truck that
killed Indianapolis Colts linebacker
Edwin Jackson during his first court
appearance yesterday the Guatemalan
citizen gave police a different name at
the time of his arrest
Alex Cabrera Gonzalez and a different
country of origin Mexico investigators
say the 37 year old suspect with a
blood-alcohol level three times
Indiana's legal limit plowed a pickup
truck Sunday into Jackson's uber car
that it pulled onto the shoulder of
Interstate 70 Jackson and his driver
Jeff Monroe both died at the scene you
have never seen a picture of Edwin
Jackson and he wasn't smiling attorney
Daniel Meacham is Jackson's Godfather
and his family spokesman they've lost
the son that brought them joy on a
regular basis where this gentleman was
from does not really matter to them
they've not interested in the politics
of it in 2005 a ray goes avala pleaded
no contest to two drunk driving charges
in California a year later he was
arrested three times for drug possession
those convictions likely helped lead to
his first deportation in 2007 and about
six months before Sunday's deadly crash
prosecutors in nearby Boone County said
array goes avala was convicted of
driving without ever receiving a license
there was no requirement his arrest be
reported to federal immigration
officials Claire corrado leads the
Indiana immigration law group is this
usual that someone would have been
or did twice and would have come back
for a third time it certainly does
happen I think any tragedy has its you
know it leads us to ask what if in this
case one of those what-ifs is if you've
never been here now array goes avala
could face up to ten years if convicted
on the federal immigration charges alone
meanwhile the family of Edwin Jackson is
planning a funeral for Monday in Atlanta
which will be paid for by Colts owner
Jim Irsay John Dean thanks